a new CBS News battleground tracker poll
shows a shuffle in the top tier of
Democratic presidential contenders
senator Elizabeth Warren has a one-point
edge now over former Vice President Joe
Biden 26% to 25%
senator Bernie Sanders is also gaining
ground the poll of Democratic voters was
conducted across the first 18 caucus and
primary States and O'Keefe is on Capitol
Hill and what's the significance of
these numbers well Anthony it's not that
Joe Biden is slipping it's just that
Elizabeth Warren is on the rise the poll
finds she's generating more enthusiasm
among Democrats who now also believe she
has a better shot than before at
defeating
President Trump senator Elizabeth Warren
earned an enthusiastic response at the
New Hampshire Democratic convention for
19 presidential candidates spoke over
the weekend the new CBS News
battleground tracker poll shows Warren
edging out Joe Biden in the Granite
State by one point
Biden maintains his lead in Iowa and is
blowing away the field in South Carolina
where he has strong support with
african-americans but in Nevada senator
Bernie Sanders is now in front of Maidan
and Warren with 29 percent support we
got a revolution to make you're ready to
do it the poll also finds that Warren is
picking up the most support from voters
changing their minds for example 29% of
voters who previously supported
California senator Kamala Harris have
switched to supporting Warren it was a
rough weekend for Harris who had to
apologize after a man attending one of
her town halls called president Trump's
actions mentally [ __ ] and she
responded with Harris later told CBS NS
Caitlin Huey burns she didn't hear the
man's full comments it was not something
that I really heard or processed or you
know or in any way condone that's for
sure meanwhile former South Carolina
Governor and congressman Mark Sanford
announced he is going to challenge
President Trump for the Republican
nomination this is the beginning
a long walk but it begins with that
first step and that's what I'm
announcing here today Sanford is now the
third Republican challenging the
president but in a sign of how tricky it
could be for them at least four states
are now planning to cancel their
Republican primary saying that the
president's popular enough with GOP
voters as for Democrats they're getting
ready for the next debate Thursday night
when Biden and Warren will be center
stage in Houston Tony and we'll be
watching ed thank you very much